[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
هذا اختصاص الاتصالات البصريه من خلال
صديق مشترك هو الرسم يعني
كل المراحل والاكتشافات لحظات حلوه صغيره
جمعتني مع اخواتي انه كنا نشتغل بمواد
مختلفه مثل الفخار او الملون على ظهر
السلاحف وكمان استخدمنا البويا بالتلوين
على الكوسا القرع المجفف وكنا نخشها
فالبزر فيها يعمل صوت الغرب والنشا مع
عجينه الورق استخدمناها لنصلح اشياء
بنحبها وكمانتي كتير يحب يصنع بايده ودوما
كنت عنده نفس الجماليه بحطها هيك بقرنه
معينه بتقربها
حواليكي مو ادوات وكذا روح بدك حدا يحس
فيه هالفكره من طبيب تجميل حضرتني خارج
حدود الورقه واللوحه وهالمواد نفسها هي
اللي رجعت استخدمتها بالاسكيزه العملي
واعطتني نتائج مختلفه لهيك انا بطفولتي ما
سجلت دوله رسم هو فنان الاول تاج جراح
ببدله خضراء وحبيت
الاخضر دخلت كميه الفنون الجميله واداره
الفن للفن قلت لا الفن للتاثير او لشيء
اوسع انا بحب البوستر وبحب الصوره
الفوتوغراف واخترت اختصاص الاتصالات
البصريه لنهايه السنه الاولى كان عنا
ثلاثه اشهر السيف العطله رفقاتي لعبوا
بعقلي انه نعمل تدريب مهني باحد الشركات
انه بنفوت لسوق العمل
دلوني عن شركه بتقبل الشباب يعني جامعيين
بالسنه الاولى قالوا لي انه الشركه من هون
لا الشركه من هون وكذا وانا فتت على
الاوتوستراد وكلها شركات كبيره وحلوه ودخل
مرحبا انا عندي انترفي وانتو عم توصفوا
شباب وفتت طبعا
بس باللحظه اللي فتت فيها للشركه حسيت
بمسؤوليه وقلت انه اذا قبلت راح استمي
يعني كل مرحله دراستي بالجامعه وكل شيء
كيف عم شوفه بالشركه من الجانب التجاري
للاختصاص اللي انا فيه من حيث تعلمت الصحف
والاعلان والاعلان الاذاعي الحمله من خلال
خبراتهم كيف عم شوف بالجامعه الجانب
الاكاديمي والفني تماما للاختص
اص اسمع دائما عباره انه اوعى بطيختين ايد
واحده ما بينحلوا هن بينحملو والفكره
تماما مثل المهرج بيتلاعب بالكرات طوال ما
هو محافظ على تركيزه وعلى الحركه هنن
قادرين يحبوا اللحظه اللي بيتشتت فيها او
بيوقع
فيدوشي
المسؤوليه وكمان علمني انه عملك اي علاقه
بمردوده المادي او بي سي في ذهبيه انت
بتصنع قيمته من خلال ايمانك فيه واخلاصك
له وانك تحاول تطوره بكل مرحله ليكون احسن
واحسن العمل شرفي الانسان عن طريق الصدفه
احد الاصدقاء طلب اني شارك مجموعه من طلاب
المدارس الابتدائي
حلو كتبت عنا مجله واتس
اوندر بالانجليزي بسوريا خلتني انمص جانب
غير اللي كنت بعرفه بالتصميم انه هو يسوق
عمل ودراسه هالمره شفت جانب انساني وتطوعت
للجمعيه السوريه للبيئه تط مستمر 15 سنه
حسيت روح الفريق بيناتهم قيمه الوقت
والايمان بقضيه وتعرفت من خلال زيارتي
للمحميات البيئيه على بلدي جغرافيا وشعب
عظيم ومجتمعه منتج من خلال هالحماس تم
ترشيحي لمشروع التبادل الشبابي يلي هو
مجموعه من الشباب من الوطن العربي وحوض
المتوسط بشاركوا قضايا
اول محطه كانت باليمن والمشكله كانت
بالقات زرع عمقها على اي زرع محطه التانيه
كانت باماره العين بالامارات العربيه
والامارات كانت بوقتها كثير متطوره
التصحر والجفاف بس كان عندهم وعي وعم
يشتغلوا حملات اعلانيه فيها الستريشنز
وكوستر ليغيروا السلوك المجتمعي العام
ويوجهوه على التنميه المستدامه واستخدام
الطاقات البديله قلت انا لحالي تمام انه
اديها الاختصاص قادر على التغيير لما هو
بيحسن يحل مشاكل اعمل محطه الثالثه كانت
بايطاليا ايطاليا شبه جزيره محاطه بالمي
تتخللها انهار عندهم نسبه هطل المطري
عاليه يعني تقريبا ما بتوقف كان موضوع
الورشه عن جمع مياه الامطار للاستفاده
منها انا فكرتهم عم يمزحوا قلت بركي عم
يحكوا عن الصرف او شيء يعني للمياه فوتوني
على متحف العلوم ومتحف المي وشفت كيف
ادوات فنيه بسيطه عملوها من التنك
والانابيب
يعني بسطت ظواهر بالفيزياء والعلوم انا ما
كنت فهمانيتها قالوا لي لو سمحتي قبل ما
تطلعي في ميزان المي مشان تشوفي قديش جسمك
مكون من المي هاي الحركه حسيتها اكثر
تاثير يمكن من كل التصاميم لانه كان
الجانب الانساني فيها عالي
بالشمع عملنا كتير تجارب حلوه المسابقه
الوطنيه للبيئه كانت قائمه على اعاده
تدوير الورق من جمعيه اهليه بسوريا
باللاذقيه استخدمنا احبار عضويه والهدايا
الدعائيه كانت اقلام قابله تتحلل للتربه
والمجتمع حب الفكره كتير والمشروع الاكثر
تاثير كان اسمه الهابي كابس الهابي كابس
الاغطيه السعيده كان مشروع قائم على جمع
الاناني لاخطيه الاناني البلاستيك تبع
المشروبات والمي بعيدوا تدويرها وبيعملوا
منها كراسي مخصصه للمصابين بالشلل الدماغي
هي قادره تعانقه من هون هذا المشروع يعني
عرفت مين المجتمع اللي انا فيه استمر له
كذا سنه وكل ما العالم تشوفني بعد شهرين
وثلاثه قالوا لي نحن مجمعين لك الاختيار
لسه في كراسي
هذا العمل التوعي بمرحله ثانيه بحب اخبركن
عنه اللي هي لان الاصعب والاكثر تحدي كانت
لما انا كنت طالب ومدرس قدمت على الدراسات
العليا من دافع الفضول البحث البحث انه
كنت عم بسال استاذي ليش هاي اللافته خضراء
وليش هاي حمراء وليش هاي بني عم شو
بجاوبني ابني على الدراسات العليا هالقدمه
على الدراسات العليا اخذت تسع سنين وسجلت
رساله بالواي فاي نظم التوجيه والارشاد
كان افق جديد لهالاختصاص اللي كنت عم اشوف
كل مره وعم يفاجئني بغناء وجوانبه
المتعدده حبيت فكره البحث العلمي ترجمه
مراجع الجديده وكنت متعطشه للافكار الحلوه
وطلعت القصه انه مو بس بدها تكون ديزاينر
بدك كمان يكون عندك مهارات لغويه وصبر
القراءه لانه لما بدك تكون كاتب جيد بدك
تكون قارئ ممتاز
اشتغلنا على مجموعه من الابحاث والمقالات
الفنيه الرساله صدرت وعملت تاثير كثير
كبير على اثارات تواصلت معنا الجمعيه
السوريه للسلامه المروريه قالولنا انه
بالسنوات الحرب كان اكثر فئه معرضه لحوادث
السير هن فئه الشباب فممكن نعمل اي شيء
بالتوعيه بهالموضوع كليه الفنون الجميله
حضنت هاي الفعاليه وعملنا توعيه للدلالات
المروريه اللي تفاجاتوا بالاخير انه
الشباب قالوا لي نحنا ما كنا عم نتجاوز
نظام السير او نقطع اللافته نحن ما كنا
فهمانين هذا الرمز
هالفكره خلتني اشتغل دوما على نشر الثقافه
البصريه وبالتعامل مع استاذي المشرف ودعمه
مراجعته للماده العلميه كان مقرر الجامعي
الاول فيجوال او السيميوتيك علم الرموز
والاشارات البصريه كتبته بشغف ومحبه بس من
زاويه الطالب مو من زاويه الاستاذ لانه
كان اختار المعلومه اللي انا كنت اتمنى لو
اني كنت اعرفها قبل او مصدر دائما غني ومن
ضمن اللي اخترتهم تدفكار تستحق النشر ما
توقعت ب 2017 انه يكون لي الشرف انه يوقف
على تيدي اليوم
كفينا
وانتقلنا لمرحله ثانيه كانت اصعب انه تدرس
كيف بدك تدرس بسنوات الحرب نحن لا عاد عنا
مراكز ثقافيه لا في ادوات او كتب وطبيعه
اختصاصنا انه غني ومتجدد بادواته ما بيحسن
اي عمل ثقافي او عامل فيه انه ياخذ من شيء
احادي القطب يكون متنوع الثقافات وغني
بالمخزون فانا قلت انه ما في شيء ولا
كهرباء ولا مي والطلاب محبطين وهيك بس
بلحظه معينه فكرت انه يا ترى انا بس رح
اقدم شيء انه يدرسوه بالجامعه ولا التحدي
انه قدم لهم اداه هن يشتغلوا لانه هنن
حقهن كمان بحياه كريمه ومن هون انطلقت بكل
حماسنا نرجع على التدريس وشاركهم خبرات
بورشات كنت عاملتها او بالمانيا او
بريطانيا او مراكز ثقافيه وتفاجات انه
الامل كان منهم وانا اللي تعلمت منهم لان
الاستاذ بيتعلم من الطالب تماما مثل ما
الطالبه بيتعلم من الاستاذ
وهل الشباب اللي نجحوا وانقبلوا بجامعات
عالميه او اللي اخذوا سوق العمل ونافسوا
بشركات تصميم اللي فهموني انه نحن صح
خسرنا خيره الخبرات وخيره الكفاءات بس لسا
عنا خيره الخبرات وخيره الكفاءات
بمحطه كانت يمكن الاجمل والاكثر محبه
لقلبي لانها كانت الاصعب لما سجلت على
الدكتوراه
اخترت موضوع الهويه مثل ما شفتوا والهويه
السوريه البصريه كانت غنيه جدا وكان
الموضوع شاقك لانه مثل اللي عم يدور على
ابره بكومه دكتورتي بالجامعه ساعدتني
بالدعم لها المشروع بكل مرحله طالب دراسات
العليا دائما يحبط او بكثير باسرع او
بانجاز اشتغلنا المشروع بمحبه حاولنا يكون
وثيقه بصريه تجمع كل عناصر وحوامل الهويه
السوريه
كانت اول رساله مدعومه بنظام كيو ار كود
بتتيح انك انت تشوف الاعلانات لما انت عم
تقرا النص كنت حاول اشتغل دوما على منتج
اصيل بكل اصرار وابتعد عن النمطيه اذا
كانت موجوده
انا بجوز ما اعطي نصائح انه كيف تعمل انت
شركه بمكاسب وبملايين ولا بحكي على منعطف
تاريخي درامي اخذ حياتي لغير قرني طريقي
كان طويل هو حجر حجر كل مرحله فيه بنت
المرحله اللي قبلها وعرفت انه انا اختصاصي
هو جواز سفر اخدني وورجاني كتير اماكن
وكان اداه تواصل وكان اداه حوار والطريق
كان طويل وجميل الانجاز وحلم لا يحده حدود
ما في شي راح نزرعه اليوم رح ناخده بكره
واهميه الخطوه اللي انت بتعملها انها تكون
ثابته ما تهوي فيك بولا يوم للوراء والمهم
ما تطفي فيك شعله الشغف وحب البحث دائما
تروح لقدام وكليك زانيكس لو شو ما صار
التصميم كان اسلوب حياه بالنسبه الي وبناء
تدريجي مثل ما كانت الحياه بالتدريج
التصميم تغيير مؤثر شكرا
[تصفيق]